what's up everyone welcome back for
another rings of power interview right
here at san diego comic-con
i'm so excited to talk to you all i i
really can't even imagine how special it
was to be able to premiere that trailer
hall age of all places yeah it was
pretty it was really surreal i think for
all of us
it's obviously been a you know a few
years since i think we all heard about
this and to be able to share it together
and share it with the people in the room
who were so welcoming and excited it was
great so this is literally one of the
biggest productions one of the most
anticipated shows coming out this year
so huge massive production but can you
each give me an example of a more
intimate quality of the production that
you know felt personal to you where you
were able to express your own creativity
and have your voice heard or maybe you
saw someone else do it it really you
know struck a chord one of the things
the show runners were amazing at was
actually allowing you that access to the
script and to
to them basically so if if there was
something that wasn't working with you
on a scene you could walk up to them on
the day and ask for something to change
and they would take on your thoughts
sometimes they'd say no shut up um
in much nicer words but often they would
they would um
change things and you would think on
something this scope with with the
amount of preparation that then time and
effort they've put into it that they
would be quite reluctant to change but
that really wasn't the case at all it
almost felt like you were on a really
small budget indie film um in that sense
so that was that was it for me yeah i
think the crew as well like the the kiwi
crew they were all so welcoming and and
nice and just always there for us as
well anything we needed they always they
were always there for us and provided
whatever and you know just even a simple
like how's your day going sometimes got
us got us going in the morning so
yeah shout outs to the crew they were
the best absolutely the best um i'll
just say because we played a family and
we became a family being in new zealand
for a year and a half there were many
moments
where the lines were blurry in terms of
caring that much for your fellow cast
and allowing us to kind of we we had so
much banter and play
and some of it made it in the show and
you know so there was a lot of room for
us to
sort of take what we developed
interpersonally and translated into the
into the show i love hearing that i
always love hearing about the value of a
good scene partner i know you guys
probably can't spoil too much at this
point but can you give an example of a
time on set when a scene partner was
just what you needed and maybe helped
you reach something in your own
character that you wouldn't have been
able to without them obviously i play uh
a female dwarf on a the first female
dwarf and i think um
we're seeing the kind of detail of of of
that culture and race and kingdom for
the first time
and so
we have so much gregario get
gregariousness um and kind of joy and
heart so to be able to kind of play
those scenes and and feel quite kind of
um
free and safe was was really exciting
and also there were moments of
there are some wonderfully intimate
moments between uh myself and of course
um owen arthur who plays during and um i
just remember regardless of where
the camera was shooting
i always felt like i had an exceptional
performance to play against and and kind
of a lot of um
yeah just just everything was really
alive in every moment regardless of what
was going on around us so that was um
yeah it was great i would believe that
i'll throw that to you too markella with
um with the relationship between um nori
and poppy
what is something about the two of you
as scene partners that kind of added an
extra layer to that friendship that
maybe wasn't on the page but can only
come through via your collaboration i
think firstly i just feel really
grateful that um megan and i just
we get on and we got on from the start
and we didn't have a chemistry test so
that was just kind of
it just it just worked out that way so i
think that was really amazing and then
we a lot of our rehearsals actually just
were comprised of a lot of improvisation
and so we kind of worked around that and
megan is just really present on screen
and really kind of open and and
um
and just a real like great comedic
timing as you'll see and just wonderful
to
to act alongside so i really thin and
upset i think that was it was really
yeah it was really important it really
helped it and you'll i think you'll
really connect with her character too i
was able to feel a little bit in the
tiny little clip i already saw i love it
uh tyro for you this is your first like
big role right this is like a very
ambitious project to start with so did
anyone give you a really good piece of
advice that you actually were able to
apply to the production process on this
i think
everyone gave me
good advice you know like people i was
working with and you know people i
wasn't working with just just purely off
the basis that were in completely
different worlds but um i think every
every single member of the cast sort of
took me under their wing
um which which i'm really really
grateful for and um
you know i was put on a massive set uh
which i'd never been on before and you
know esmel and nars in particular
obviously you know their experience
helped me a lot and um they made me feel
so comfortable and um
i'm so i'm so grateful for them and
and yeah they helped me produce
the work the work that i did which i'm
really how does your character feel
about the relationship that his mother
is in he's not happy
you could say that you can say that a
little um obviously the history between
uh the humans and the elves
um you know thousands of years prior um
my you know theo's ancestors sided with
morgoth and uh fought against the elves
and and sort of in punishment uh for
their you know doing they got banished
and had to restart in
in almost the slums-esque um of the
southlands
and uh it's patrolled by the elves and
you know and it was generations ago and
and theo thinks and bronwyn thinks and i
think the whole village thinks that it's
time to move past it and move forward
but the the elves just won't forget so
there's a
lot of tension in there and especially
when your mom is dating one of them it's
a bit
you know
i could keep you guys here all day with
follow-up answers to these questions i
wish we had more time
for you now
when your character poster came out the
first thing that caught my eye was
obviously whatever he was holding is
that a farming tool or is that a weapon
has no one asked that i was sure someone
was going to ask that already it's a
walking stick
yeah
and um now i feel like there's more
meaning to walking stuff
it's a walking stick okay i'm afraid i
gotta leave it there all right no i'll
take that that gives me something to
work with
i like preserving the mystery until i
can actually see the show
sofia for you
this is your first on-screen role yeah
this is my first big tv role yeah yeah
uh years of theater so um is there
anything about acting for the camera
that called for like a really big
adjustment or a change to your process
lots of the words and
and the kind of um the technicalities of
it all but i think what was great is
that um
again linking it to the dwarven race um
and actually this piece and this
franchise there is a theatricality about
it um so i was able to kind of transfer
a lot of those skills of of be just
being really open um and being able to
be unapologetic with showing every
single facet of emotion
um that that that level of detail was
was warranted and celebrated within this
production and and and on um you know
on set
so so i was kind of being able to use a
bit of both but there's these hilarious
stories where you know in the world of
theater if there's silence you know
you're really poised you're ready you're
ready to go at any moment yet to kind of
um keep the the show must go on the show
keep moving in case someone's forgotten
their line and so a lot of the time on
on set uh right in the beginning
uh there was moments of of silence but
everyone had said okay we're rolling
we're ready to go we're ready to go and
um there'd be silence so i would just
walk on ready with my prop ready to go
and and i just turned and i saw rob
romeo who plays l rond and and um uh
during my husband shoulder shrugging
you're just laughing and i'm going
what's the problem and then they said go
back do it again and i just keep walking
on and rob was like you've got to wait
for action
you're not supposed to walk on it oh yes
yes sorry sorry so just kind of learning
all those technicalities where to look
eye lines that was all the
technicalities was the thing to learn
but the um the emotion the spirit the
acting you know it was 15 years in the
making so she's brilliant in this
so you wouldn't even you wouldn't be
able to tell that it would be like her
first
like that is yeah
just wanted to say that again i've only
seen the tiniest bit of footage
and spoken to some of you briefly but i
can already tell that the dorindissa
connection there and their relationship
is something that has already popped for
me more so than anything so to dig into
that a little bit
last we spoke you kind of told me that
you know they're on the same page
they're they're a team but what is like
the biggest difference between you know
whatever they believe in or how they
approach getting what they want or
fighting for what they want i think the
biggest
uh i'd say the biggest
difference is that durian is torn
and decent is not
diesel knows exactly what it is um that
she wants and that she thinks is right
for
her and her husband and her kingdom you
know she is um
a female dwarf for the people um
she is for her kingdom she is for the
heart and for the good of everyone
around her and i think so she knows no
bounds and sees no other way but the way
that she wants to walk and of course
during has so much to contend with with
of course his father and london
relationship so that's a little bit of
twoing firing for him but um mama knows
what she wants every quality i hear
about them i'm more and more drawn to
them all right charlie for you now i
know
the meeting of hal bran and galadriel is
a big thing for the starting point in
his journey in the show but it was
making me wonder have you ever thought
where he might go in life had they not
met when they did what path was he on
there's a chance i mean had he not met
her that he
might his life might have not gone on
and i think that that's
interesting in
that moment when they first meet
they are survival to each other it's
like if he hadn't met her he was still
stuck on this raft
in the middle of the sundering seas
so i think that
their fates crossing paths open up it
opens up this whole world for hal and
makes him question
so many things in his past and then
it also makes him reassess the kind of
man he might be in the future it gives
me something to work with and try to see
the whole thing play out i like it uh
markella for you now i know nori is
trying to subvert her foot tradition
what is it that inspires her to do that
is that something innate to her like
from birth or is there something that
happens that puts her on that path and
such a good question i mean i think she
has an innate curiosity that's for sure
and i think i really wanted to make sure
that it wasn't
it didn't come across as something that
was a purely out of just selfish
interest in the unknown that it was you
know she's very aware she's had to
she has to bear this responsibility and
she's had to for a really young age to
care for
her siblings and her family and and the
community in a way that she's probably
had to grow up a bit too
too fast too quickly um and so
i i thought that it just made sense to
ground that in in wanting to improve
subvert her foot tradition to improve
the quality of life and that that's
where the curiosity into the unknown
comes from as well you know that she
leads with the idea that a fear of risk
can be greater than the risk itself and
that you know she's just constantly
pushing that but
it's sometimes it gets people into a bit
of danger but it's it's
you know half what's in danger but it's
with the best of intentions still do
like the general idea of subverting
tradition to make life better for
everyone yep should bleed well beyond
this show
i have to let you all go i could sit
here talking about your show all day
long which is incredible because we
haven't even seen any episodes but it
gives me something to look forward to
huge congratulations i hope you enjoy
comic-con and everyone out there is
already doing this but look out for
rings of power
you